on
um Zone and to those of us who are those
of you who are joining us on the live
stream
um I had received apologies from
councilors skeleton Arnold but they're
not actually members of this committee
so we can note that for the next
committee meeting when I think it would
be appropriate to receive those ones
Grant I'll leave that here
um any Declarations of interest that
anybody has to raise
if not uh that brings us into the first
item and open which is the minutes of
the community well-being committee from
Tuesday December 13.
I'll move to a true and
correctly thank you any questions
Mr chairman I apologize for that meeting
and it's not recorded it was a 30 I
haven't got my iPads on family but that
was the 13th of December is that correct
so we'll make those amendments Barry no
important
so with those amendments
put it all in favor
uh application for grant funding for
from the invercargill licensing trust
Stephen welcome to the meeting
Stephen councils have had a chance to
read through but if you want to
highlight uh any
um
prominent issues in the paper that would
be good
was that sorry do you want to provide a
summary of the paper uh yeah so thank
you good afternoon mayor and councils
um this paper is purely just a process
that we go through to apply for funding
uh to the iot for the iot schools learn
to swim program uh it's been running
since 2008. a very successful program in
the community
um
if I'll take the reporters read and
we'll just open it from discussion from
there
councilors there are
two recommendations
counselor kit yeah thank you Mr are you
moving or you can ask questions I'll ask
a question okay can I I'll get get the
item on the table first did somebody
want that move really obviously thank
you this sorry where you go better okay
uh there are three notificall absence
there of the schools uh I hope I went to
North and Waverley or W's down the end
of the alphabet
and it's iron another swimming program
or was it just been an oversight
I would say they got chopped off the
bottom of the list
again had a good look one of the most my
old school
they are included they are and still
standing
another question please
have uh have you approached the ilt
prior to this meeting today to talk
about this the funding not not as yet
Council uh
I think would be more professional Mr
chairman of the ilt had been approached
prior to being published in the paper
and in an open Agenda here
it's part of a standard process then
since 2008.
there's nothing new in this application
as opposed to others others too
no
um the iot are very supportive of this
program so I did have a voicemail
message when I was away last week from
the LT I'm just asking to get last
year's
accountability sorted and that advised
me of when the applications closed for
this year's round of funding so it is
they are expecting an application but it
does need to go through the formal
approval process of council yes that's
correct too okay
further questions Peter
I'm happy in the meantime thanks
bring it then Leslie
thanks Mr chair yes Stephen just looking
at obviously this is mainly for schools
and there's there's absolute valid
reasons why it's full but looking at the
stats
um for the last two years of drownings
um the over 65s the highest percentage
of people drowning now
um would you do you open it the training
to to elderly people for that do you get
much take up
um we we do offer adult swimming lessons
yeah the best part of this no not as
part of this because it's purely for the
schools purely for the schools yeah just
wondering if if you know take up just
looking at those stats are extremely
alarming and and obviously I just
wondered what what would motivate those
uh those adults to try and go you know
if it was uh maybe free
there there's a possibility yeah no just
not
sure of the answer to that yeah it was
just it was it was amazing how uh
disturbing those statistics are for
adults
yep um I guess
with this application there's always
been
a strong link between the ilt and
um education and some of the projects
that they've funded
um I don't know that they've looked
beyond that but it's a you know it's a
relevant point that can go out there in
the community and perhaps be raised
raised with them thanks Patricia
um through YouTube I'd just like to say
how valuable this is we are really
looked on as being very very fortunate
to have it in our education um community
and um it's it's very important and it's
very valued
sorry Leslie oh thanks Mr chair I didn't
have a question I just wanted to say
as Trisha's just said look this has been
since 2008 an absolutely well respected
and high delivery program I think um all
those schools uh very including the
three whose names are Mr
very appreciative of it and
considering how bad the statistics have
been for drowning deaths just in this
last summer it really does emphasize why
this program was put in place in the
first place to create a generation that
that did have a great deal more
um sense and appreciation of of water
than perhaps some of those drowning
statistics so I'm just an absolute fan
of this program really pleased to see it
here and I wish it great success in the
next year
thank you Peter yeah thank you Mr chair
so if we're successful with the full
amount we're applied to the iot
foundation for there is a shortfall I
haven't got as I said I've got my iPad
in front of me there's a short four to
council have to top that up to Fresh
Palace or see you uh through your chair
so um it's a partnership program so
um Splash Palace subsidized entry and
the iot
funding covers uh the cost of some
teachers
um pool space and transport
yeah so it will cancel transfer funds to
Splash Palace or it'll just be 182 736
that's all spacecraft will get is that
right or yes uh so city council receive
the the funding amount via the iot and
then that's what we we work with
right
so we counsel ourselves when they have
to top up a splash palace with a extra
money
not not for the program we've not
subsidized the industry so we we
basically
um safely just don't charge yeah yeah I
understand thank you Evelyn
uh yes Mr chair through you to
um
there have been in the past
programs specifically directed at adults
do we have the opportunity to apply
similarly to those or are they not
currently being run because I'm I'm just
trying to search my mind back I can't
remember exactly but I think ACC in the
past have funded and I have an idea that
um there was a national sort of adult
learn to swim campaign some years ago
do the polls professionals have input to
ask about things like that
is there a possibility of that because I
am aware that the statistics
don't really pertain to controlled
swimming environments as a role these
are sometimes people making
um unwise decisions in open locations
but having said all that
is there anything that we as an
organization can do or apply to to offer
our citizens those opportunities to
improve their their skills in the water
uh yeah through YouTube
um definitely you have the capabilities
to do some work around that and
investigate some options
and I guess part of that would include
gauging interest
indeed maybe some of the statistics that
have been around this summer might
prompt a few people to
consider it so it's worth worth having
to look at not part of this application
obviously but
any other questions or comments
if not then I'll put the Motions all in
favor
aye against
carried
uh there are no other items in uh open
meetings so we have
uh to go into public excluded
um but we also have uh
financing projects so Grant do you want
to
um come and do the open finance and
projects and then we'll go and do the in
committee bits afterwards to save people
having to leave are you comfortable with
that yeah
well then I'll adjourn this meeting
oh a good point so we'll go into public
excluded and then adjourn um for this
committee yours will be an open meeting
so the items to be discussed
um around the South Museum and art
gallery trust board and PX so I'm happy
to move that councilor Soper I've got
that all in favor against carried we are
in committee and